hey everyone this is Steve want robe
with Collider I'm here at South by
Southwest with everyone behind Mickey
and the bear thank you guys so much for
coming in thanks for having us before we
get started the only reason Collider
gets to be at South by is because of our
great sponsors I want to give a huge
thank you to supper suite to El Tesoro
tequila blue moon hint water everyone
that's responsible for getting us here
is great because it's you know covering
festivals is what I call expensive and
you need sponsors to make it happen so
thank you it's cool we've been drinking
tequila and water all day that explains
so much about you that yet so you guys
just had your premiere if I'm not
mistaking like a matter of hours ago I
was gonna say what the hell was it like
sitting in that theater premiering your
movie and be you know what I mean for
everyone else who had to sit through it
and for the first time in a room full of
300 people because I know the feeling
and it's yeah I just saw it for the
first time and and I just I'm just I'm
so filled with like love and joy for all
the people I'm sitting up here with
right now because these guys are all
badass ninjas and it's a beautiful movie
what they said let me ask you this
everyone watching this interview except
for pride two people will not have seen
the movie yet and I hate asking like the
generic thing but can you talk a little
bit about what the film is about and for
all of you guys a little bit about your
characters yeah so the film is about a
young girl named Mickey who is living
alone with her father he's a young man
he's a veteran he is struggling with
addiction in in light of both being
discharged and losing his wife very
early on in life and it's kind of just
about the codependency and love in their
relationship and it tackles the way that
you can kind of have unhealthy habits
within families and specifically with
the father and daughter yeah and it
takes place in Montana I play Hank the
father
I play Mickey I play Mickey I'm 17
turning 18 in the film and it's about my
relationship with this guy and all the
ups and downs of our father dynamic
father-daughter dynamic and I'm not
gonna give the rest away I play I play a
hank Peck
Mickey's Mickey's father and you know
Hank he's uh they don't know they don't
know okay so what you should know is
that Hank is you know Thank You Hank you
struggling some things you know he loves
his daughter and I think he's he's
trying to do the right thing but uh he
gets in his own way and unfortunately
that affects his uh his family and the
people around him thank you I'll play
Wyatt Hughes I'm an aspiring musician
who's I don't know what to say without
giving things away yeah I've got a thing
for for Mickey
I play dr. Leslie Watkins and I'm a
psychiatrist at the local VA hospital I
play Erin Church
he's like born and bred in anaconda
Montana where the film takes place he's
really enjoys being from there and wants
to stay there and he's sort of Mickey's
high school boyfriend I'm curious the Oh
Polly opioid epidemic right now is so
severe and I'm curious how much that
plays into the movie and you know how
much talked a little bit about that well
I've said this before I don't think you
can tell a story about the Iraq or
Afghanistan wars without talking about
the opioid crisis and particularly in
this story where Hank is struggling with
multiple disorders both mental and
physical the first thing the VA does is
peddle him with pills and give him
painkillers and they're incredibly
addictive so in this story we see that
struggle through a young girl's eyes so
we don't necessarily see everything but
one one moment she might come home and
and see her father not like who
normal self and that's terrifying for
somebody that's 17 so it was really
important for me to present that crisis
from the eyes of a young woman because I
think that that is very rare lacy and on
screen I've seen firsthand what
addiction does to people I'm curious
talk a little bit about portraying
someone like that and you know a little
bit of what you learned maybe doing the
research for the role I've I've been
around it and I've known a lot of guys
who were in the service and who spent a
lot of time in some very dangerous
places and have come back and or
continued to try to actually go back
over there because it's a part of life
that I think they understand a little
better in some ways that makes them more
calm only be careful about what I talk
about I think a lot of the stuff that I
do to get ready to go to work I'd like
to keep personal but I also think it's
our job as actors to bring a very
personal level of our own experiences to
it and I talked to Fanny and there were
some things that I was trying to work
through personally there was obviously
also the the opioid side of this but uh
there's the the brain damage size of the
CTS the CTE side of everything and you
know I'm you know I'm not afraid to say
it I'm someone who has I've had
repetitive concussions and about ten
years ago I went to a very dark period
in my life and I'm not through that now
and you know thanks to friends and
family but um it's these are these are
real important issues and I think they
need to be talking about one of the
things that I think that society in
general doesn't do enough of is you know
it's a lot of lip service to the
veterans and the people that fight for
our country and then they come back and
I'm not sure how it's portrayed in this
film but the VA seems to be very limited
in what they can do either through
resources or what their whatever the
reasons I'm curious if you if you if the
film touches on that a little bit
it does but again all of these issues
are being experienced secondhand and
through the eyes and body of a young
person and a young woman exactly so it's
very much about like okay if my dad is
struggling like how am I going to kind
of go about helping him and with maybe
you can talk a little bit about with the
VA you know in anaconda there's a very
dense battle at veterans population and
there's incredible people out there but
they have very few resources and unless
you have a really great great
infrastructure to like support you when
you are just hard and come back home
it's really hard to get back on your
feet I don't have much more to add I
think dr. Watkins is like one of the
good ones
but I do think that there's just there's
no resources basically yeah and dr.
Watkins sees something in michie where
she actually is a human being and like
wants to help and yeah and wants to you
know if she can't necessarily help Hank
maybe she can help Mickey I just I just
wanted to bring it up just because it's
something I feel very strongly about and
so you know for for each of you I'm
always curious about like memorable
moments from filming and what it was
actually like on set making a movie so
could you each share maybe a little bit
of like a day that you'll always
remember from the shoot the most
memorable moment was just a scene that
was like I didn't really think about it
all it just like I'm coming to her house
to try to get her to go to a party with
me but it just ended up being like
really fun and we sort of went off
script and improvised and sort of that
was a good day
well my first movie make out was with
what my first kiss was with Ben but my
first tongue kiss and that was my first
tongue kiss on camera and I have to your
mind me pausing there I just have to ask
is that like a direction like this is a
heavy make out their tongue with him in
the moment one was like a locker kiss
that you'll see in the school which is
more like a pack and the other one was I
understand I'm just curious
yeah right I'm just curious how the
direction is that you know what I mean
so slightly move on from the kiss my
favorite moment a most memorable moment
was when I saw like a real-life bear
just cruising about all three of us were
involved in it and we had to stop and
show it in for a bit whilst this bear
swam across yeah it was crazy my dad
just like fully takes off after the bear
we're like where did that go he's like
[Applause]
we also have to make sure we're safe we
also had buckets full of food because it
was a there's a video and he sent me a
video from on the other side of the
river where some of our crew was and
were based out of there and you can see
the bear and then you can just hear
someone's voice go hey hey hey badge
badge I wouldn't do that buddy I have no
words for that because I would be going
the opposite way or you know at least
freezing I'm not the smartest guy in the
world yeah I don't know I want to get
closer to bear I mean the bear looked at
each other I was like cool he's like
yeah cool I'm like all right you good
yeah I'm good and I went back and shot
the rest of the movie I'm like I'm
basically out of time but I really have
to ask you about the editing process
it's my last thing because ultimately
editing is the final rewrite and I'm
just curious how did the film change in
the editing room and maybe from early
friends and family screenings well my
editor Henry and I work really closely
together and he did everything for me
and I don't know it took a lot of
different forms we shot for 25 days so
we had a lot of scenes and I think it
kind of came down to really whittling
down the movie to be Mickey's story
because there are so many other threads
and there were so many supporting
characters and so many other interests
in her life but it really came down to
like her journey of self-discovery on
that note I mean I have so many other
questions but you know you guys have to
do other interviews today and but I'm
just gonna say thank you right I have a
bear in the back right I'm so sincere
when I say I cannot wait to see the film
and I wish you guys nothing but the best
and thank you so much for coming in our
studio at South by and thank you to
supper suite seriously thank you
you